Welcome back everyone it's Charlie bring
yourselves back online this is going to be
my Westworld season 3 episode 5 video
everybody gets to see their Facebook
data if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a giveaway for HBO now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet obviously we'll do top
10 and easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode is genre that's a reference to
the club drug that Caleb was on during
the episode that makes him experience
life through movie genres through the
episode but the actual beginning of the
episode starts with Serac explaining the
rest of his backstory we got a teaser
for that in a previous episode we see
him on the outskirts of Paris as it's
being hit by a nuclear attack so it just
sort of explains how they came to create
the Rehoboam system they get really deep
philosophically about the meaning of God
whether or not God ever existed so they
decided that because God needed to save
the world
they would have to create a god for
themselves and that is the Rehoboam
system or what it would eventually
become because they went through several
different beta versions on the way to
this current version of it he also
teases the idea of flies in the ointment
there are problems that the system can't
detect or account for this is explained
in the outliers the agitators that they
talk about later in the episode and how
they bring things back around at the end
and how he deals with Liam's father so
number nine in present-day Serac
controlling this foreign president is a
great example for how he's using the
Rehoboam system to influence the course
of human history how to push people
around like chess pieces on the board to
do things the way he thinks they need to
be done so that humanity won't kill
itself but I like the way they sort of
ease into it here like he's got this
foreign president telling you about this
rise in insurgent group they're going to
cause problems this is how you deal with
them it's full blown Minority Report
this is going to become a problem in the
next couple of weeks if you don't deal
with it right now
even 1ups the president saying that oh
your intelligence groups only know what
I allow them to know most of you
probably sense what their relationship
was when they first started talking
about this - he reveals to the president
that he helped get him elected in the
first place and if he doesn't do what he
wants him to do stop cutting all those
secret deals they within about six weeks
he
going to be talking to his replacement
who's that guy right over there with the
big mustache one of the same people on
the military staff that the president
was so confident was going to defend him
if something bad was going to happen a
couple seconds ago how quickly things
turn around and really cool side note
even though I'm sure technology has
reached this level all over the place in
the jet the Serac is flying on is just a
normal corporate jet it is really really
cool-looking so number eight the back
story continues Serac and his brother
meet Liam's father and insight and we
get a much deeper dive on his brother
who we've only heard about previously
they explained that was actually Liam's
father who controlled the insight
company in is the basic Mark Zuckerberg
of this equation collected everyone's
data before there were data privacy laws
but they needed that data so they could
create a model for human behavior the
human mind so that Rehoboam the system
could do what it does predicting the
future we learn about the beta versions
it's Saul David than the Solomon version
that they were on in this flashback here
before it became Rehoboam so the whole
idea is that those are successive Kings
from the Bible David became King after
Saul David's son was King Solomon and
then I believe Rehoboam came after King
Solomon you could also get really
biblical with the metaphors of what
they're doing on the TV show right now
to and present day to try and control
the world in the Bible when Rehoboam
became King things became incredibly
chaotic which is what happens during
this episode back in present day we get
an Easter Egg for the different versions
of Delores when Serac finds out what
she's doing communicating with each
other they say the system is detecting
an anomaly happening at five different
places all communicating with each other
at once those are basically the five
different versions of Delores we know
who for them are and one of them
destroyed themselves in this episode but
we still don't know who the mystery
fifth version of Delores is seven Liam
doses Caleb with the genre club drug so
obviously he starts experiencing life
through different movie genres through
the episode it doesn't really affect the
plot of the episode it just adds some
extra context and flare to the
storytelling the way they talk about the
genres later in the episode it sounds
like everyone who takes the drug
experiences the exact same genres it's
not unique to each person so he starts
out in the 1940s in a noir genre it
sounds like everybody who takes the drug
starts out in that
staged the way they cut the scenes is
you only really see the different genres
when you're taking Caleb's perspective
so every once in a while you do jump
back to Dolores's perspective and
experience things in real time but
number sixes is a big one because they
convinced liam to give dolores his
access key to the Rehoboam system he
keeps trying to tell them that he
doesn't have the level of access that
they want to truly control the system
he's not quite sure what they want to do
with probem they haven't told him their
whole plan but you remember back in the
first episode he says that Serac when
his father died completely cut off his
access to all the really important
functions so he really only has the
ability to search people's profiles and
just do low level things but that's
really key to what Delores is trying to
do in this episode liam spends most of
the episode fighting them on everything
and then trying to mock them later in
the episode when they actually do free
everyone's data the way they really get
him though is by making him freak out
thinking the serac wants to get him
because he's trying to outbid him on
Delos not knowing that it was then that
stole the money it is trying to outbid
him on Delos so Serac doesn't know quite
everything that's going on he doesn't
have full context he just knows that
Liam's money is trying to outbid him on
Delos but they haven't really picked up
in that plotline there's only three
episodes left so I'm assuming they're
going to bring the del of stuff back next
week while they're trying to hack the
system and save themselves they also
remind you that insights software
controls almost everything all the robo
taxis all this low-level software is
sort of a callback to the beginning of
the season in episode 1 showing you how
deeply incites software controls and
influences people's lives the Rehoboam
system tells them how to live their
lives controls the implants in their
bodies that regulate body functions or
medicines that they're taking that also
come back around when we talk about the
outliers and the agitators and that
quote unquote secret white facility with
all the people with mental health issues
they have a couple really cool chase
scene moments here especially with the
smart bullets that Dolores is able to
reprogram mid-flight oh no don't worry
you didn't miss just give it a second
everyone press F in the chat to pay
respects for Dolores motorcycle it
sacrificed itself so that they could
live as lena waithe and Marshawn Lynch
come back to help them out and they
escape the next big genre the Caleb
experience is kind of like 1960s pop
punk when Iggy Pop starts playing the
number-5 back in the past Serac explains
how he knows
there used the system to predict the
stock market so in order to get Liam's
father to back off they had to show him
how he could make a lot of money so they
said they started with something
quote-unquote really simple
basic math problems and that was
predicting the stock market they have a
bit of a funny moment where he makes a
hundred million dollars on the spot and
he's like where did you get this money
from you stole a hundred million dollars
from the company know we stole five
million dollars last week it is such a
simpleton and so greedy that that's all
they have to do to get him to back off
and let them do what they want to do
with the system but nothing good can
last forever Serac explains that
eventually they started to see problems
in the system the agitators the outliers
the people that the system could not
account for that he tried to find a way
to deal with and he implies that most of
those people were actually the mentally
ill because that's all the people in
that white facility that you see later
he also explains how people started to
use the system for really shady purposes
like Liam's father using it to push
outcomes to benefit himself make even
more money getting even greedier but he
reveals his brother was also trying to
use the system to predict a way that he
could get rid of Liam's father so number
four surak's agitators and outliers so
they go to that secret white facility
and this sort of ties back around a
caleb's storyline they sort of raise a
couple big questions with what's really
going on with his character but I think
it's all implied based on this storyline
and these moments here you find out this
Iraq put his brother into their testing
facility it's kind of a mental
institution but also a facility for them
to test how to treat people using the
Rehoboam system I think that has
something to do with those biomedical
implants like you see the implant the
Caleb had in an earlier episode when the
thugs were trying to torture him they
turned it way up on him
whatever they are they secrete whatever
kind of medications the person might
need to regulate their mental health
functions and as bad as Liam's father
seems during the episode he's one of the
people that asked that moral question
wait a minute no you can't edit people
like this you can't edit human beings
the way you edit code in a computer so
rock doesn't care he feels like he's
helping humanity and doing a good thing
for everyone keeping humanity from
destroying itself the way he tells the
backstory is that unless he deals with
these outliers and agitators humanity
will always lead itself to destruction
like every possible future timeline
always leads to
the end of the human race and if you
already didn't feel like all this system
controlling people's lives wasn't
already sinister he also says the system
tries to get rid of these outliers and
agitators by pushing them into the
military into war zones so that they'll
get chewed up and spat out all as a way
to get rid of some of those outliers so
the system itself isn't killing these
outliers and agitators is just pushing
them into situations where they're most
likely to wind up dying just to get rid
of them even faster as part of this
storyline him quote-unquote editing
people there's an even bigger moment
that they leave the episode on that I'll
talk about in a second - he implies that
he has even bigger things in play but
then number three Delores hacks the
Rehoboam system sending everyone their
full profiles past present and future
and it does exactly what you had
expected to do full-blown chaos in the
streets some people actually find out
really good things about themselves you
see some of them chilling out running
around the streets some people get
really terrible news like there's the
businessman that finds out that all of
his co-workers have been trash-talking
him this whole time
lean away finds out that something
really terrible happens to her brother
she gets bummed out for the rest of the
episode for the most part the system
doesn't predict any kind of happy ending
for these people mostly horrible
terrible things happened to them and
their family members in the future
so while Serac feels like he was using
the system to help everyone caleb sort
of balances that in the episode when he
tells his backstory about the rats
likening them to society you're giving
everyone false hope it's way worse it's
way more torture when they never had a
chance to begin with so it was sort of
the balance in the episode like who is
the villain in this equation is Delores
the villain because she's trying to give
everyone their data and creating all
this chaos or as Serac the villain
because he's trying to control everyone
the final genre the caleb experiences as
they call it is quote-unquote reality
watch out bro you're experiencing
full-on reality now as the shining music
starts playing i love the theme song -
it's so sinister like oh this is what
reality is really like then as they take
Liam to the beach there's a nice
callback to earlier in the episode
something that Caleb said as you see
this dude standing in the beach looking
like he's getting ready to kill himself
that's basically what Caleb was telling
Liam earlier in the episode you think
I'm going to wind up on the beach putting a
gun in my mouth
speaking of which number two Liam tells
Caleb he's the one as he's bleeding out
after lena waithe shoots him
so while he's experiencing this final
genre he starts having these crazy
flashbacks to him being strapped in a
chair looking like something's being
done to him and he was part of a group
of people that was killing this guy here
and he starts seeing flashes of his
friend played by kid cudi who's one of
the other celebrity cameos during the
episode so he starts having all these
flashbacks and memories while liam is
telling him you're the one you're the
one that did it and I think the
implication is the caleb is the one who
actually wound up killing his friend he
just doesn't remember it because they
altered his memory and because they're
trying to create this parallel between
Caleb and Delores humans being on this
sort of loop trying to throw the loop
the way that the host tried to throw
their loop in the first two seasons of
Westworld is that maybe what's happening
in these flashbacks has something to do
with what serac was talking about and
quote-unquote editing people fixing the
quote-unquote agitators the number one
we finally have a face-to-face
direct confrontation with Dolores versus
sera cuz they sort of tell each other
off the really interesting thing here
too is Serac implies that he's got some
final fix in play for Humanity like
people are flawed humans aren't perfect
but I can fix that that I think also
ties back around to what's happening
with Caleb's character and all these
flashbacks that he's having so hopefully
they'll explain that either in next
week's episode or in the next couple of
episodes but everyone let me know in the
comments what your favorite part of the
episode was if you have any big
questions or any big Easter eggs you
spotted that I didn't mention in the
video episode 6 will drop next week
there's a bunch of big stuff happening
this week I'm doing a big MCU rewatched
with big Easter eggs for Marvel phase 4
so just leave all your video requests in
the comments below
everyone click here for that very first
infinity saga Marvel rewatch video for
Iron Man and click here for all my other
Westworld videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight!